Hey Thoughty2 here
With the wide reach of the internet, we’ve
seen how fast a meme can spread and then,
before you know it, they’re gone again like
a ghost in the night .
But this also happened before the internet
too. Let’s have a look at some crazy crazes
and fabulous fads that took the world by storm.
Now in the modern world of consumerism, we
all buy plenty of stuff that we don’t need.
In fact, that’s probably most of what we
buy. This means that selling us useless products
has become something of an art form and led
some people to wonder; what won’t people
pay for?
In 1975, Gary Dahl, gave a pretty convincing
case that you really can sell absolutely anything.
For just under $4 he gave you a smooth rock,
one you could have just picked up off the
beach or a river bank.
Pet Rocks were probably the biggest craze
of the year and although it died out within
about 6 months, it was enough time for Gary
to become a millionaire. Your rock came in
a little box, with a bed of straw and a 32-page
user guide, explaining the difficult task
of feeding, grooming and training your new
best friend.
He hit on the idea when he heard his buddies
talking in a bar, complaining about having
to take care of their pets; all that food
and poop and walks and eating your shoes and
making your house hairier than a barbershop’s
floor. So what if you could avoid all these
irritating issues and have a simple pet that
loved you, only the way inanimate granite
can love? A rock is cleaner than a dog, quieter
than a hamster, probably friendlier than a
cat and at least as intelligent as a goldfish.
It’s a win win.
Gary sadly died in 2015 but he wanted everyone
to share in his super sales powers. In 2001
he wrote the famous; advertising for dummies.
Who the dummies were in this situation, was
not exactly clear.
Whether it’s rocks or cats, pets are hugely
popular and it seems like our love of cute
animals is unlimited. But trust Japan to take
it a little too far.
Kigurumi are the animal costumed performers
that you see at many promotional events, sports
shows and so on. But the cutest army in the
world burst onto the streets in the mid 2000s,
seen getting on with their daily lives dressed
in a range of cartoon onesies.
Japan has been obsessed with cuteness for
a long time and their term “Kawaii” can
refer to everything from clothing to shows
to behaviour, even food; who doesn’t want
a sandwich with an adorable face, right?
Many trends have grown out of this, from the
creepily named fashion of “Sweet Lolita”,
which consist of lacy bonnets, bows and umbrellas,
as well as whitening make-up, to things like
Hello Kitty and burikko ji, a style of fake
child-like handwriting.
The most popular Kigurumin outfit was probably
the little, yellow, rodent Pokemon; Pikachu,
partly because of the character’s mass appeal
but also because the bright yellow colour
masked a lot of the mustard and tea stains
that your daily onesie wearing normally creates.
The mighty power of cuteness could not be
contained to Japan for very long. Soon, students
across the UK and America were nursing their
hangovers in furry style. It’s hard to feel
sorry for yourself when you are a unicorn;
I think that has been proven by science.
Speaking of science, our next craze shows
just how quickly our understanding of something
can change.
In 1898, Marie Curie and her husband Pierre
discovered Radium, element number 88 in the
periodic table. It’s a metal and has a half-life
of between 3.5 days and 1600 years, depending
on which isotope you’re dealing with.
For those of you who aren’t sure; let me
quickly explain the basics of what a “half-life”
is. If you have an amount of a substance which
is radioactive, then its atoms are not completely
stable. So, they sometimes decay and send
out particles of matter (alpha and beta) or
energy (in the form of gamma rays). The half-life
is a prediction of how long it will take before
half of the atoms in your lump of stuff have
decayed. It’s really more of a probability.
The crazy thing is; if you had a piece of
Radium just the size of a grain of sand, with
a half-life of 1600 years, it would still
be decaying at a rate of around half a billion
atoms a second!
So, back to the craze. When it was announced
that Radium could be used to attack cancer
cells, people went Radium crazy and it became
a health fad. They put it in lotions, syrups,
tablets and plenty of other stuff. It was
basically the Kale of the early 20th century.
Unfortunately, while Kale is just a simple
leaf, Radium makes you sick to your bones,
since it often causes cancer there. Marie
Currie herself died of a cancer to her bone
marrow and it took us a while to come around
to the dangers of handling the substance.
Some of Curie’s possessions, such as her
old cookbook, are still dangerous enough now
that they have to be stored in lead-lined
boxes. The French government is still cleaning
up traces of radioactive waste from the Radium
craze to this day.
We didn’t realise the problem soon enough
and it was used across Europe and America,
both in medicine and also for its glow in
the dark quality. A famous court case arose
around The Radium Girls – a group of women
who had been painting watch faces with Radium
paint. They would lick the tips of their brushes
and it was a few years before they realised
they were poisoning themselves.
Speaking of paint, when I say graffiti, most
people are going to think of street art like
Banksy or JR, or maybe you’ll picture some
toilet scribble written with a Sharpie.
But for as long as there has been bored people
and walls, we’ve had graffiti. And one of
the most widely spread doodles is ‘Kilroy
was here’.
It’s difficult to pin down a real origin
for this, especially because the quote and
the image actually come from different places
but got combined at some point during World
War II, probably due to all the soldiers hanging
out and killing time together.
The image was seen as early as World War I,
known to Australians as Foo, and to the Brits
as Mr Chad. He’s ended up with plenty of
other names over the years, such as Herbie,
Overby, Flywheel, Private Snoops, The Jeep
and Clem.
The British Mr Chad would often appear with
a slogan saying “Wot, no tea?” or “Wot,
no sugar?” as a complaint about rationing.
As for the image, it could have been taken
from lots of things. One popular idea is that
it comes from electrical circuits, since the
Australian version often had a plus and minus
symbol for eyes and resembled the diagram
for a sine wave, or even the omega; a symbol
for electrical resistance.
The phrase “Kilroy was here” is American
though, and is likely from a ship inspector
called James J Kilroy who would sign the phrase
on parts of the ship to show that he’d checked
them. Since production during World War II
was so fast, often parts would not get painted
over, so navy personnel would find his phrase
scrawled in the most unlikely corners of the
ship and this is maybe how the legend was
born.
It was so popular in the 40s and 50s that
it’s said to have been drawn on everything
from the Great Wall of China to the Statue
of Liberty and, rumour has it, even the moon.
It’s also popped up in plenty of books,
with a nod from Isaac Asimov, Robert A. Heinlein,
Thomas Pynchon and even Bill Watterson, in
everyone’s favourite; Calvin and Hobbes.
You’re at a party and what better way to
get things going than with a dance? It doesn’t
matter if you’ve got no rhythm or you’re
not wearing the right shoes because today’s
dance just involves walking under a stick.
That’s right, it’s the Limbo; the dance
that broke a thousand hips. It has everything
you’d want from a dance; terrible music,
awkward poses and a high probability of horrific
injury. The strange thing is; this dance originated
in Trinidad and was originally performed at
wakes. Nothing says “you will be missed”
like rubbing your nipples against a flaming
stick.
The 1957 film Fire Down Below is where the
dancer Julia Edward introduced Limbo to a
wider audience and Chubby Checker’s hit
single Limbo Rock in 1962 helped to popularise
it.
It’s not as common at parties these days,
it’s hard to limbo to electronic music I
guess, but as a competitive sport, it’s
still going strong. The current world record
holder is Shemika Charles, a local Trinidadian
who’s keeping the tradition alive. In 2010
she danced her way into the Guinness world
record book, shimmying under a bar just 21.5
cm high; that’s less than the height of
the Guinness record book itself! She even
went all the way under a car.
Limbo is part of a long list of dance crazes,
allowing drunk uncles at weddings all over
the world to look as ridiculous as possible
whilst trying to show up their in-laws.
While most people can at least attempt to
dance; our next craze was popular because
of its innate difficulty.
The Rubik’s Cube was a multi-coloured puzzle
guaranteed to make you feel as dumb as a monkey
holding a smartphone. Invented in 1974 by
Ernő Rubik, a Hungarian sculptor and professor
of architecture, the cube is about 6x6 cm
and has a 3D cross in the middle with 26 plastic
cubes attached around it. The aim is to arrange
the cube so that each side is all one colour
and no, you’re not allowed to just peel
off the stickers.
Over 350 million Rubik’s Cubes have been
sold around the world and it is the best-selling
toy in history. It’s notoriously difficult
for most of us since there are a staggering
43 quintillion different combinations. But,
for a few fast-fingered brainboxes, it’s
a piece of cake and the world speed record
stands at just 4.90 seconds, by 14-year-old
Lucas Etter.
Various other forms of the Rubik’s cube
have appeared over the years, with increasing
numbers of sizes and shapes; from a simple
four by four cube, up to a Yottaminx. Now,
a Yottaminx is a regular dodecahedron, meaning
it has twelve faces, all pentagons, which
divided into 15 by 15 pieces. It needs 2,943
parts to make it. If you do manage to solve
it, it opens up a much more important puzzle;
which is, what are doing with your life?
Our next craze was also a puzzle, of sorts,
but the pieces were people. In the late 50s,
phone booth stuffing became a challenge that
spread through colleges across North America,
Britain and South Africa and on 20th March
1959 a world record was set when 25 South
African men managed to cram their way into
a phone box, at the Durban YMCA.
And this remains the record, despite the many
different attempts made and a variety of techniques
that students dreamed up, whilst doing their
best to avoid any actual work. A Canadian
school managed to get forty in a booth but
they had tipped it on its side and used one
that was already larger than average.
So rules were set up, regarding the size and
position of the phone booth, as well as how
much of a person needed to be inside to count
towards the total. The Brits took it one step
further. Since we’re sticklers for doing
things properly; you had to make or receive
a call in order to complete the attempt.
“Yeah, Hi mum… just in a phone box with
39 other people, I think I might be late for
dinner”
If you want to try it for yourself, then the
sooner the better, for the mighty phone booth
is becoming extinct. In the U.S, the peak
number was 2.6 million in 1995 but that number
has plummeted and it’s now well under 500,000
and dropping every day. With the prevalence
of mobile phones, a phone booth is basically
a tiny, smelly museum with bad advertising
and some suspicious flyers.
If you were thinking about making a call in
Brazil, and leafing your way through the phone
book to look up a number, you might start
to notice a rather wonderful Brazilian craze
that is still going on to this day; giving
your children crazy names.
In some countries, such as Denmark, there
are very strict laws around naming a new-born.
There is a list of approved names, around
7000 in Denmark’s case, and the name must
correctly indicate the gender of the child.
In Brazil though, it’s practically a competition
to see who can come up with the longest, obscurest
names, referencing everything from historical
figures (for example Francisco Lindon Johnson
Menezes da Luz Junior), also numbers (such
as Dix-Sept Rosado) or office equipment (like
Xerox Porfirio).
So what’s the reason for all of this? Well
it’s hard to say exactly. No doubt the rich
history of immigration and colonialism had
a big impact on the naming culture and there
has been a feeling of higher class attached
to some countries outside Brazil, such as
the US, so therefore names associated with
these countries probably hope to adopt part
of their perceived glamour. Although I’m
not sure Oleúde José Ribeiro, would agree.
This footballer’s first name is supposed
to be ‘Hollywood’ but the Brazillianisation
has lost a little something along the way.
He’s not the only comically named player
either, he’s beaten by Credence Clearwater
Couto.
So what if Brazilian folk tire of being referred
to as Mao Tse Tund Lima de Moura or Oceano
Atlântico Linhares? Well you can legally
change it but the court system is very slow
and difficult and many people just choose
not to bother, embracing their parent’s
decision and buying an extra wide ID card.
Brazil doesn’t have a monopoly on creative
nomenclature though. Frank Zappa, the American
rock genius, had four lovely children named;
Moon Unit, Ahmet, Dweezil and Diva Thin Muffin
Pigeen.
Our final fad is one close to my heart, because
I played it on many a sunny afternoon back
when I was a kid. It is the ferociously competitive
game called; Conkers.
Conkers are horse chestnuts, known as Buckeyes
in North America, and they usually start falling
from the tall trees in their green spiky shells,
around the middle of September. Unlike their
brothers, the sweet chestnut, which have a
much spikier shell and pointed seed, they
are not edible, in fact they are very mildly
poisonous.
But since they are found lying around outside
school yards, kids were smart enough to put
them to good use. The aim of conkers is to
smash your opponent’s conker. You drill
a small hole through the middle of the conker
and then attach a sting. You take it in turns
to strike the other person’s conker until
one of the conker cracks. It’s basically
British Pokémon; with conkers instead of
Poke Balls and cute furry animals.
There was actually a classic N64 game called
Conkers Bad Fur Day but it was platformer
about a dirty mouthed squirrel, rather than
a very niche conker battle simulator. Typing
BOVRILBULLETHOLE in the cheat menu here would
give you 50 lives, but cheating in actual
conkers required a lot more effort. Some of
the more popular methods were boiling them
in vinegar and then baking them, or painting
them with nail polish. But if you really want
to be king of the playground, World Conker
Champion, Charlie Bray claims that “the
best is to pass it through a pig. The conker
will harden by soaking in its stomach juices.
Then you search through the pig’s waste
to find the conker.”
Hey, sometimes you’ve got to get your hands
dirty if you want to be a real winner.
We roll our eyes at every stupid new fad that
comes along but we all know, deep down that
we’ve been a part of something just as ridiculous
before and probably will be again, it’s
what makes life interesting, right?